hmm welcome to the civilian playing
water fighter from Argentina right this
route yes then we got a Queens gambit
accepted let's see a play down the solid
III line yeah see fire from the northern
Korea but he takes a while ok cancel I
don't really have a good light nick gets
this I always played it takes you five
the somewhat check somewhat lame Queen
exchange line but it always um yeah it's
a bit of a nuisance for black you can
rarely win a game and down once in a
while why to really get something the
little thing but something okay let's
see how he sets up his pieces while
usually retreats the Bishop to e2 and
tries night be three not FD for various
ideas to put some pressure on the
queenside let's see maybe this is an
idea because now the the bishop has a
hard time to not get exchanged you know
I can play b3 and Bishop e3 I don't
think that he was aware that he allowed
this okay give the check room or is
there something better now the check is
the check is certainly ok so is he going
to play b5
b5 this maybe even I'd see five yeah
this is obviously a nice position but
how do you really get something concrete
don't know
okay this is a position where you can
think of all if you if you have the time
to try to get the best possible result
it's difficult and at least for me to
judge what's the best ok b5 mmm-hmm I
can play night see how f he goes before
how do i get get ahead here maybe bishop
f3 this could be an idea set up the spin
the bishop is nicely placed on f3 king
king to e2 it's still not so easy for
black to free himself ok I thought
nights you five would be really good ok
I need to do this anyway no use in
spending time I cannot really retreat
the night or anything and let's do that
ok and now it's no way to to keep it on
c4 all right
I'm sorry yeah this isn't optimal I
didn't really want to retreat
hmm yeah maybe this isn't so great or or
did I did I miss something
hmm not Ricky you don't really want to
play before time in a min a pin Dwight
it uncomfortable pin
now maybe I need to play before but
first let's go here
he can play a five
for beef or for that matter mmm Todd bit
shaky I must have done something wrong
was very nice this position and this is
some this is not clear at all and I is
taking some time okay yeah I didn't
expect this move but ok whatever I need
to take it prolly yeah at least them
there is less pressure now on on c5 at
the moment
okay come on I need to get rid of get
rid of this him 50 he captures on f3 and
I'm taking with the point I also could
show deform the spin is really annoying
yeah you can again play rook c8 now it
doesn't
hmm
I will do how do i get get out of this
bloody pin
and before is playing a five and he
threatening 93 on top of all of that
because Roxy aight i can play night d 3
i think i think i can do that figure
with Roxy a the plane I d3m this is
important look see wanna shop c1 Knight
c3 and okay you didn't come to that yeah
still though still the same problem I
don't see how g6 is nothing but I cannot
do do anything great here
I could action with the bishop why
didn't I do that I'm taking on c5 is
very strange of course no one else if
the pattern game check check you know my
father better and game black resign the
ID was it was very strange to to take on
c5 why not just rook c8 not much is
happening this was very strange the spin
all the time probably he had some
something really good at at least one
point I really should add here for
example I should just mix this bishop to
get out of this bloody pin and then it's
it's about but equal i think but i'd
really like to know around here I think
white should turn yeah why should be
better with those active nodes and those
weaknesses here but how to learn how to
make any progress it's difficult and
played rock after you wanna this looks
very normal and also this now he played
rook c8 hmm yeah okay I am I played this
one and then be five this is the problem
I must play they should be 22 so that I
can go to e5 it's not it's not fatal for
black or anything but I probably need to
do that here I'm always in this pin this
is really a problem and I nobody should
be too and there aren't here i'm in them
in trouble no no doubt you played some
moves that I didn't really understand
maybe rook c8 directly putting pressure
here and something like before
chichester sample line it's quite good
this is a weakness this pawn the black
is nope like it's very quick with active
aging skin yeah this is very stupid
piece the only thing it can ever do is
so protect this pawn for a moment yeah
very lucky winner at the end thanks for
watching